(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre a documentação
expedida após um leilão excrediticial.
Via de regra, logo após a finalização do
leilão excrediticial, o leiloeiro vai elaborar um auto
de arrematação.
Esse auto de arrematação nada mais é do
que informar que ocorreu um lance vencedor, vai
informar os dados do arrematante, os dados do
credor, do devedor, o valor da arrematação e
a forma de pagamento daquela arrematação.
Após a elaboração desse auto de arrematação, a
regra é que seja elaborada uma escritura de
compra e venda e esse documento vai ser
o necessário para o arrematante levar ao cartório
de registro de imóveis competente por aquele imóvel
para registrar a propriedade em seu nome.
Quando a compra for financiada, vai existir um
novo contrato de alienação fiduciária.
Afinal, para realizar esse financiamento, o arrematante vai
ter que dar uma garantia ao banco e
a garantia que hoje em dia é usada
é a alienação fiduciária do bem imóvel, que
o próprio bem imóvel vai garantir o pagamento
daquele financiamento.
Nesses casos, não vai existir escritura pública de
compra e venda e sim um instrumento particular
com pacto de alienação fiduciária.
Nesses casos de financiamento, então, esse instrumento particular
com pacto de alienação fiduciária vai ser o
necessário para registrar a propriedade em nome do
arrematante.
Uma observação muito importante, para a nossa legislação
aqui no Brasil, só é proprietário quem registra
o imóvel, então você como arrematante não pode
deixar de registrar o imóvel em seu nome
mesmo que seu objetivo logo após a compra
seja vender aquele imóvel, afinal, você só pode
vender o que é seu, então você tem
que registrar o imóvel em seu nome e
depois realizar a venda normalmente.
Assim como em uma compra tradicional, esses custos
de escritura pública e registro são de responsabilidade
do arrematante, então entre em contato com o
cartório de registro de imóveis e pergunte qual
é o valor de uma escritura para um
imóvel de um valor X e recorra àquelas
listas que eu deixei disponível na aula de
calculadora do leilão no módulo 1 para saber
o valor do registro dentro da faixa de
preço do imóvel que você vai arrematar.
Alguns estados permitem que o próprio auto de
arrematação seja o documento necessário para que você
registre a arrematação em seu nome e, nesses
casos, não seria necessária a escritura pública ou
esse instrumento particular com pacto de alienação fiduciária,
o próprio auto de arrematação seria a documentação
necessária.
Isso é realmente bem excepcional, a maioria dos
cartórios espalhados pelo Brasil não aceitam esse auto
de arrematação, sendo necessário realmente a escritura pública
ou o instrumento particular de alienação fiduciária, mas
saiba aí que existe essa remota possibilidade de
você economizar o custo da escritura pública.
E também para fechar a aula, quando você
faz a escritura pública de compra e venda,
essa escritura tem um custo, quando vai ser
registrado o instrumento particular com pacto de alienação
fiduciária, não existe esse custo cartorário para realizar
esse instrumento particular, porque esse instrumento particular, como
o próprio nome diz, vai ser realizado entre
as partes, afinal, é um instrumento particular, vai
ser realizado entre o arrematante e o credor,
aquela instituição financeira que levou o imóvel a
leilão.
Então é uma possibilidade de você economizar o
valor da escritura, só que isso nem sempre
vai ser realmente uma economia, porque esse instrumento
particular, geralmente os bancos eles cobram uma taxa
para que esse instrumento seja elaborado, e essa
taxa ali, às vezes ela pode ficar bem
próxima do valor da escritura, então já considere
realmente o valor da escritura, mesmo que a
sua compra seja financiada, para você ter um
parâmetro ali de que você vai gastar após
a arrematação.
Jogue isso tudo lá na calculadora, que ficou
disponível no módulo 1, para realizar as contas
e até para saber qual é o valor
do seu lance máximo, porque como a gente
já falamos, todos os custos que você vai
ter com a arrematação e após a arrematação
devem ser considerados.